it's different it's different it's
different well I'll tell you why but
it's impossible for a female to be
promiscuous on a long enough period of
time without devaluing herself because
she is [ __ ] people she shouldn't be
[ __ ] there's no way she is sleeping
with endless men and all of them are
either high value men or treating her
the way she should be treated if you
find a woman who slept with 50 100 dudes
she's either [ __ ] dudes which are at
her level or haven't worked hard enough
to try and get the [ __ ] she was just
too drunk to realize he's a loser who
plays video games or she's [ __ ] a top
G who barely texts her back so either
way she's [ __ ] dude she shouldn't be
[ __ ] or a guy who's at the level who
doesn't give her the right amount of
attention for a woman to find a guy
who's truly on a level who truly treats
her the way she should be treated that's
once every couple years if that you
ain't just gonna go out there [ __ ] a
new dude every week and say yeah he's
worth [ __ ] yeah he treats me good
enough to get my [ __ ] and you know
what's funny about the universe it's
actually beautiful about the universe
because it's equal and opposite forces
when you